well the lecture series is mastering the
middle gates and that's a notion you can
just choose what you want to what what
you want to do and somehow I thought it
would be most appropriate on the eve of
the US Championships to simply do
something fun okay
and sometimes when I study chess and I
just get too tired of it I'm working too
hard or I'm not making the progress I
want then I just simply want to enjoy
something just you know it doesn't
matter if it's a beautiful study I'm
about to show you a very very beautiful
game and the game was played quite a
long while ago in Sochi Ukraine in 1958
and the white player is a grand master
level eagle ski and the player with the
black pieces is Rashid Nez Medina and
Nash Medina was something out of a
science fiction novel book I mean he was
a remarkable remarkable player and the
single most unconventional player I can
think of is Nash Medina and he's not
very well known to Western audiences at
all whatsoever
and I suppose the best way I can
introduce him to yourself is to quote
from a book from leva Albert I should
remember the book that I'll forget it
but it's a love Albert book where he
talks about stories from the Soviet
Union
and what happened was there was a very
strong player I'm going to say
thomashefsky who came from Siberia a
region in the Soviet Union was very very
desolate very few people from the major
center Tomsk in Siberia and that player
and again I believe it was toshka
tuchkov ski had a remarkable success
that allowed him to play in the Soviet
Championships which was the pinnacle of
chess in the Soviet Union to get invited
into the Soviet Championships was
extraordinarily difficult and many
grandmasters simply didn't make it so
you have to think of a pyramid with all
of these leagues many many leagues
leading up to competitions that would
lead to a qualifier and qualifiers that
would lead to semi finals and semi
finals that would lead to the final and
Tomashevsky from this place in Siberia
nobody ever heard of is qualified well
this really shocked the Soviet Chess
Federation and the people in Moscow
because they think they have everything
under control they know who is coming
who is going and they have this fellow
nobody ever heard of and he qualifies
for the Soviet championship without any
coaching without any seconds so they
said to Thomas chefs key that they were
going to send him a top trainer a
grandmaster from the Ukraine but of
course that top trainer didn't want to
go to Siberia would with thomashefsky so
instead they met at Moscow and it was on
the eve of the Soviet championship and
thomashefsky had black on round one
against Tigran Petrosian and the trainer
said to tell moshevsky well really we
shouldn't prepare for this game tomorrow
why not says Tomashevsky well
Petrosyan he will take complete control
over the e5 square you will put you in a
bind and then he will kill you so no
reason to prepare and exactly as the
trainer suggested would happen happen
Petrosyan got complete control over the
e5 square put the man in a bind and
completely crushed him was totally
one-sided ah game - never mind
aim - who do you play today ask the
trainer and thomashefsky said I play
measure Medina ah no reason to prepare
why not and some where in the middle
game he will sacrifice upon then he'll
sacrifice a knight and then he'll
checkmate you in exactly here is what
the trainer suggested would happen
happen thomashefsky fired the trainer
trader went back to the ukraine very
unhappy he said why did he why did I
lose my job I told it the matter what
happened and it happened just as I said
I left bollock ifc of course was in the
1980s 90s in the world's top ten players
he played many times in the inter zonal
z' and candidates and Soviet
championship he was really a top player
and I got to play him often myself and I
said love could you please tell me about
Roger Medina net Nez Medina
read mesh Medina Danny immediately was
like Nash Medina he was a terrible
player a terrible player do you know I
beat him 12 times I know I didn't know
that
he said you probably only know of the
game he beat me and I said yeah he said
I would trade the 12 games I won over
the one game I lost this is the one game
that they and they had many drawers and
again measure Medina was one of those
players he was so unconventional he
played a lot of different lines in his
sole objective was he was a tactical
maniac he came after your king I mean
you didn't you're white for crying out
loud you don't know if your Kings going
to go to the Kings side maybe it's going
to the Queen side maybe I'll stay in the
center measure Medina is coming after
your king yeah that's all you really
need to know so d6 okay um it's a little
bit offbeat but certainly a playable
move essentially black is saying that
hey maybe I'm going to go a five maybe
I'm going to go into a Benoni maybe I'm
going into King's Indian who knows maybe
my bishop will come out to f5 if I I
don't know what I'm going to do what are
you going to do okay Knight c3 Trisha
decided to play e5 okay efore it's been
well known that this ending which at
first looks very presentable for white
is actually not that bad a deal for
black black has lost the ability to
castle but on the other hand he very
often will play the move c7 c6 and this
King will find a safe Square uncie
if that had any inclination whatsoever
as to what was going to happen in this
game he would have traded Queens left
luck played the conventional movie for
just grabbing control of the center
everything's fine no problem and Rasheed
captured captured knight c6 so black
gains a tempo against White's Queen and
White's queen is forced to back up but
then comes the question where should the
Queen back up
on the one hand if you go all the way
back well that's fine and then maybe
black is just kind of stolen the extra
developing move he got is Knight into
the game and love back up with this
Queen to d2 which at first sight seems
like a really bad move because the Queen
of course interferes with the
development of the bishop on c1 but love
has the idea that black is going to fee
in shadow his bishop so love will
fianchetto his bishop so they'll cancel
each other out and the Queen on d2 will
protect the bishop on b2 so Queen d2 was
a superior choice to queen d1 g6 b3
Bishop g7 Bishop g2 castles everything
nice
nothing to talk about just it's a
position white considers himself to have
the much better position because he's
got firm control over the d5 square and
it's true that's a very nice square but
it takes some time and just because you
have a good control of one center square
doesn't mean that something isn't going
to happen on other squares Bishop d3
developing the pieces bringing them out
all very good what was that
Knight g4 raise your hand if you saw
that one coming I mean what's Knight g4
well actually after you get over the
shock of the move it actually makes a
lot of sense because from blacks point
of view black has a problem he really
doesn't know where his Bishop on c8 is
going and wherever the bishop on c8 goes
then the question is where am I going to
put the Queen and then where am I going
to put the rook there's a lot of
unanswered questions on black side of
the table and because of this Morosi
bind with these pawns on e4 as well as
c4 it makes it very hard for black to
open up the position when we see the
move Knight g4 we go oh I get it and it
becomes immediately obvious to us black
is going to play f5 so that the bishop
will come out and maybe with the rook on
f8 and the knight on g4 there will be
some operations and tactics maybe
against the pawn on f2 so the move
Knight g4 paves the way for f7 f thought
v and black wants to develop his game
okay white develops an IG - did I tell
you this guy's a headhunter Queen h4
okay that's kind of like a second shock
you know like Queen h4 wow it just comes
out of the blue and by the way I want to
capture this pawn with if on f2 check
don't even think about castling because
I'll checkmate you on h2 okay Nigeria to
block the threat everything's okay
night chief for you you know now you're
starting to think wow maybe black has
some kind of early initiative and your
first thought is that you want to stop
your opponent from castling so you want
to maintain this construction and maybe
this night should come to e5 and
continue however if we look a little bit
deeper for just a moment we see that
after the move Knight e5 the bishop
would drop back to c2 and then you start
to have some nodes if you play the move
f5 for example here then after a
captures on f5 let's say I don't know
captures like this then you start to see
that wait there are ideas of f4 in the
position there are ideas for white of
Knight d5 and by the way suddenly and
when you've committed yourself to fully
to the king side white may go Queen side
so Knight g4e 5 and that looks kind of
like a reprieve for white so white okay
now I'll castle hahaha so I it's all
very happy I think about the position
from White's point of view for a moment
he's connected as rooks he's fully
developed he's got great control of the
center you know love is actually looking
forward to a nice day at the office
f5 ok this isn't a major concern but
maybe it should be because if it was
black to move the next thing you know
this pawn would go to f4 and then maybe
to f3 and suddenly it's a wipeout
White's King is just about going to get
killed okay so it's love I why
did not want to play a four because oops
now g4 we're back in business
this guy is hanging and if you move that
make the move h3 then this guy is
hanging not to mention that there's also
this check King goes here Queen takes
threatening made on h2 oops
checkmate so no f4 okay so love plays f3
just keeping it keeping it nice and tidy
and after the move f4 not a problem
he'll just drop back with his knight and
life is good black and we'll have a good
night on e5 but very very shortly a big
night will arrive on the D PI square
then the pawn on c7 is weak and then
black will be thrown on the defensive
well that was at least loves plan
suggestions for black what do you think
black should do in this position just
toss out well what do you think yes
black should do in this but yes you know
you're thinking like measure Medina
that's exactly right Wilson
he did indeed play Bishop h6 it's an
interesting thought isn't it that this
knight on e5 is really beautiful but at
the same time it blocks the diagonal of
the bishop on g7 so the bishop pops out
to h6 who knows maybe on a good day it
goes to e3 square with chat maybe to f4
we're not sure love drop back with this
queen now again this check looks very
compelling you would go check King h1
for night here and you think oh that
Bishop on e3 is very very nice but then
again you start to have some doubts
because you see that white as soon as he
puts as knight on d5 will have a double
attack both against the pawn on c7 as
well as the bishop on e3 the bishop gets
up eliminated on e3 this Bishop on b2
looking down this diagonal well there
could be some issues Rasheed played a
four immediately okay said well now
we're in business
Knight comes back from White's point of
view once again all he needs to do is
play Knight d5 and then he's going to be
attacking this pawn on c7 and at the
moment it doesn't appear that too many
dangerous things are happening on the
King site let's go come on g6 g5 Knight
to d5 g4 let's attack so black has some
massive threat suddenly if you play
Knight take C 7 oops but we can all see
this coming Cantley g3 h3 Bishop takes
h3 if you take the rook in the words of
my trainer and nickel I'm in EV White's
going to die with a full tummy because
Korean age to checkmate is on blacks
agenda
so after g4 white played g3
a a little bit scary but
back the only thing that's leading the
charge is the Queen and if we do the
immediate check King comes up Queen
checks the King comes to e3 and it's
completely safe King in the middle of
the board and furthermore White has his
own ideas rook to h1 attacking the Queen
and also this Bishop on h6 also to
mention that the pawn on c7 is under
attack
so after f4 it's black to play black to
play give me some ideas what do you
think black should do give me some ideas
mmm kind of tough right white's knight
on d5 blocks up the position not too
many pieces to take yes Winston what do
you think which one Knight f3 check
we had just looked at and we didn't see
exactly how we could improve the
position white is white is ready to run
with this King that didn't work we need
something better really good
Bishop takes f4 well Bishop takes f4
rook takes h4 keeping in mind that when
you're defending it's a very good idea
to defend to trade defensive pieces for
attacking pieces we can suggest maybe
it's not true but we can suggest it at
least that this rook on f8 as an
attacking piece and it's in White's best
interest to trade off his defending rook
on f-14 the rook on f8 Knight takes f4
Knight check King f2 Queen check because
of course the knight on f4 was attacking
the Queen King III and right now we're
piece down and it doesn't seem like
we're getting anywhere again rook on a
eight out of the game bishop on c8 not
exactly in the game at the attack either
we need something better
Wow well that's very I mean that's very
inventive Bishop g5 I I mean this game I
have looked at this game probably 2030
times in my career and never thought of
that movie I'm not so sure Bishop g5
with the idea h5h for it feels a little
bit slow I
I suspect that white if he didn't want
to do anything like taking the night he
could play a move like Bishop c2 and
just also pardon me there is the idea
that I can take the knight because
there's no Bishop III check the knight
defends the square yeah so we have a
problem what are we told by our coaches
we should do Wilson yeah that's a good
advice get rid of your opponent's best
piece but also good advice is to develop
Bishop e6 let's get on with it Bishop e6
let's develop well wait a minute isn't
that a terrible move because once you
see Knight take c7 you start to be
afraid and if you're not afraid it means
that you're not thinking there's a fork
here but remember the knight on d5 was
doing some really good defensive work it
was also protecting the square on III
and it was protecting the square on f4
now the gentleman's idea a moment
suddenly starts to have it impact whoa
Bishop takes f4 in case of G takes f for
g3 give me checkmate if you play rook
takes f4 rook takes f4 G takes f o g3
and now again you've got the same
checkmating ideas that you had before
you can't go Knight takes check and mate
and what about after g3 if you go Knight
takes all then simply King takes and you
can see that this Bishop is on e6 is
about to move into the game with with
fourth and this night on c7 is captured
upon and that's all so that that there's
no Knight take c7 runs into BAM captures
on f4 left polygons he saw that and he
played Bishop back to C - okay now
what are we going to do let's see if you
did it you might work out seven
developing taking the night is a very
good move taking the night as a very
good move the problem with taking the
night immediately is that after Queen
takes this kind of comes with a check
it's going to slow you down a little bit
with this check when he played the move
rook f7 he's really waiting he's ready
to double rooks
black wants to double rooks and like
those variations we saw a moment ago
maybe he's going to sacrifice two rooks
isn't a bishop in order to just to get
his pawn to g3 square so rook f7 first
now well-loved understood what was going
on the guy wants to bring his rooks over
he's going to take the knight also let's
say in this position if it was black to
move if you tip the knight on d5 and the
Queen recaptured on d5 it's no longer
check so that black could then play a
move like night before forking the Queen
which would be on d5 as well as the
Bishop which would be on DC to left
decided it was time to run get ahead get
the get get that King out of the corner
and bring it to the center okay
what did Rashid play
dad have you seen this game before till
you get some credit guessing the Meuse
shall we go further let's see what he
did
check rata mountains and takes very
simple
so now as Wilson was saying eliminate
the good piece of your opponent you took
away the bishop on the knight on d5 with
the bishop recaptured with the pawn
Knight d4 now some strange things are
beginning to happen we start to imagine
in a fantasy world that there are ideas
of Knight takes d5 if you were forced to
recapture with the pawn and not the
Queen the king could be exposed along
the e-file there's ideas that look I'll
just bring my rook into the game maybe
on a good day I'll bring my queen over
here and don't forget there's still
ideas of Bishop takes f4 check in the
position rook h1 attacking your queen
oh my if the Queen moves the Queen moves
to g2 then after Queen g2 rook takes h6
check the king happily just dances away
and the prey escapes so we can't move
our Queen because we're just going to
lose our bishop we'll lose the game
we need a good move Wilson yeah baby
rook takes f4 bang whoa
now you can't take with the knight you
take with a knight this is too easy
four black black then just takes this
pawn and he'll pick up this night so
he'll only have invested in exchange for
two pawns and a raging attack if you
take the pawn with the rook gosu Bishop
takes check Knight takes Knight takes
check whew okay suddenly hot in the
middle of the board you have to give up
your queen and after clean takes Queen
takes now if you're not laughing at this
moment people oh my gosh poor love like
I have ski so what did he do of course
left captured the Queen very nice it's
queen ahead what are we going to do
suggestions yes that's a good move go
ahead Winston tell me now you saw
something wrong okay well your rook and
your bishop is hanging yeah rook F three
double check King comes in the middle of
the board a moment ago that King was on
g1 and it just flew right up to the d4
square your queen now it's a time to
resign which one c5 check well that's a
really good interesting move let's see
c5 check okay I have no choice I have to
capture on pass on Bishop e3 check the
King could go back to c3
now the knight is hanging on b4 we're
still not out of Dodge but it's not
super clear so here you are don't forget
your queen now can you imagine what
Rashid blade Oh bravo Bravo Bishop g7
whoa wait a minute you're a hole Queen
down and look what you have in mind you
have in mind just a quiet move B and
double check mate
okay and the bishop on g7 you know at
any moment can fly and with a discovered
attack now let me see what loved it here
left played the move a for because he
was afraid of b5 in knight c6 where a
mating net is just being woven and when
I first saw this game I thought why
didn't love at least try to get rid of
this rook this rook on f3 controls these
important flight squares for the for the
king
get rid of the rook so I thought let's
give Knight G wanna try showing of
Knight you want to try and what would be
the answer tonight g1 are desirable we
for some strange reasons we're just that
white king somehow does not get mated
when we play c5 and we try to force the
checkmate it's just not there
rook takes g3 very good night comes back
to e2 I'm trying to get rid of the rook
rook comes back to f3 Knight comes back
to g1
well black one upon the g3 pawn what's
next
rook f8 okay ah rook
I think rook a f8 well I definitely get
rid of the rook the other rook can I get
rid of this guy I'm there's all kinds
because all kind of the bishop on b2 is
hanging they work on h2 is hanging hmm
which one night ed3
check check
I cannot play C 5 e 5 that's a that's a
pretty mate so I have to play King C 4
well now what do we got b5 check very uh
we could take b2 with check so we've got
okay so let's see we could go b5 check
King takes b5
remember that King came from g1 hotel go
here cross the board and well somehow he
slipped away okay so he slipped away so
how about Knight takes B to check King
takes
ooh
don't give up on the variation yet fine
Bishop c3 check where can I go I can't
go here this is a checkmate on the spot
so I got to go into the side pocket b5
then hide on v2 controls it and now
you're threatening check and mate
Knight C for Bishop D for Queen Knight
takes f3 Queen takes f3 a5 a5 Knight
takes Tanks Kachemak neat huh using a
rook he never developed to checkmate his
opponent on the a3 squared that's crazy
so we go back to this position and in
the game night g1 was not played because
it would have been refuted by the
variation we just saw instead that was
wide left played a four just to stop
that mating idea
now we're warming up to the task
aren't we a lot of fun black to play we
just played this great move Bishop g7
nice quiet move he's just played a for
the tables been set how do we figure out
a check mating net mm-hmm went quiet I
like it lots of fun possibilities
tough shall we have a look shall we have
a look
see five check with no choice now we got
to make a pass on not what do we do if
we take with one of the nights we let
the King escape right or not necessarily
escape we got a new checkmate on the
agenda c5 how can black possibly stop
let's check me Bishop d3 in order to
give his king at the escape square c3
okay there's so many tempting possible
your queen now you're just a queen huh
and it's like White's completely
helpless a queen up it's tough huh what
do you think go ahead
let's take a look night on III takes d3
check and if I go King here d5 check I
have to take
okay
sweet right let's just see what he did
was he played Wilson he played your move
technique isn't that there's an amazing
game so again this class is about
mastering the middle game and learning
strategies and I show you a game like
this you just know whoa if I could play
like that I'd be it on a different
planet it's chess is also about having
fun right just having a real pleasure
and you see a game like this and you
think to yourself wow it's just it's
just great this King this white king
went on ji-woon all the way down to a6
and the winning setup were the two
knights and the rook on a8 that never
moved in the game this game was
celebrated all around the world of
course and it's celebrated here today
and it's again it's on the eve of the US
Championships where there was a game
last year which I thought was just
fantastic and if ever you just want to
have fun look at the game between Wesley
soul and Hikaru Nakamura from last
year's US Championship it was a King's
Indian
hikaru sacrificed the kitchen sink drew
drew Wesley's King out and it checkmated
him very very nicely and these look well
I'm not saying this game but these are
the kind of games that we're looking
forward to at the US Championships so
we're hoping that you'll join us and
enjoy the fun